ses élèves versaillais ont un professeur
de boxe un peu particulier ils écoutent
et essaient de reproduire les mouvements
du champion l'apprentissage d'un sport
en respectant son adversaire c'est
message de de bonheur de de
joie de leur apprendre que le les sports
de combat ne sont pas des sports
dangereux c'est vraiment du toucher sans
se faire toucher c'est un jeu de
cache-cache et la discipline c'est
vraiment ce qu'on essaie de faire passer
aux enfants aujourd'hui grâce au sport
je ne suis pas passé à côté de
je pas fa des choses mauvaises jeis pas
pass à cé de ma vie j'ai vraiment réussi
par rapport au sport ça m'a appris
beaucoup une hygiène de vie et une de
conduites très très favorable pour la
vie le c'est aussi l'occasion poures
sportif de haut niveau de s'affronter
sur les Green dans le cadre d'un tournoi
caritatif de golf par équipe de 4 et
encadré par un joueur
professionnel uni pour la gag c'est une
déformation
génétique i tur donc dès qu'on fait
quelque chose on essaie de le gagner euh
c'est difficile de de le faire comme ça
en dit détente donc on va essayer bien
sûr de gagner la compétition même s'il y
a une paire de chaussettes à
gagner un peu plus loin sur le green du
trou numéro 7 les joueurs du
parissgermain éprouvent quelques
difficultés au peting les joueurs du PSG
sont bons au golf
on est encore meilleur sur le terrain je
pense que avec un club dans les mains
mais ça va ça dépend pour qui mais mieux
sur sur un parcours on essaie de prendre
du plaisir c'est le plus important le
plus important tibreak ce sont les fonds
récoltés qui permettent de construire
des centres éducatifs pour des enfants
des favorisé cette année 27000 € de
promesses de don iront notamment à un
espace multisport à pentin en scenne
saint-nis et à une communauté de
communes
sénégalaise